the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright and with that I think we'll be
ready to start on lecture 7 not really a
lecture we're just talking about lessons
from the Sprint tournament and you could
wind it complain about the map set and I
would totally support you because that
map set was crazy so I'm just gonna have
a seat here and I'll bring up this
little Word document that I've got where
we're gonna talk about a few aspects of
maps a few aspects of teams so let's
let's zoom let's do them right on in so
map dependent stuff which is which is
written here so we saw a bunch of stuff
that really killed a bunch of teams like
we had minds in the way of spawn make
sure you check that you know you don't
try to spawn a unit on top of a mine
that's another thing if a unit is on top
of a mind for whatever reason he should
probably try to move in previous years
we've had spawn delays so that when a
unit is spawned it can't move for a
certain number of rounds but not this
year he can move immediately so if
you're on top of a mine and you have a
hit point number X and the round the
defuse time is y and you know the number
of rounds it would take to kill you with
the mine dealing damage Z you just do
the math and see whether it's worthwhile
to try to defuse it because you know you
can't have multiple units defuse the
mine on different rounds it doesn't like
continued diffusion progress so anyway
they'll just die and we saw some real
hero mines that have been promoted to
Supreme Commander and they're now
commanding fleets in the Pacific the
another thing was encampments so
sometimes the encampments block off
other things I mean certainly we saw a
lot of teams lose because they built
encampments around their base and
couldn't get out like ok so it seems
like a dumb thing when you're looking at
it but how do you check for it in the
code like what's the best way I mean it
would be obvious to just try to maintain
a diagonal line straight from you to the
enemy and never lay bases on that line
but maybe there's like that's the only
base so I don't know exactly what the
best way around that kind of problem is
the yeah so they can the encampments can
sort of block each other off or you can
block off the enemy we saw some of them
like you couldn't get to those other
ones let's see if I can open up that map
oh gosh what are the chances I'm going
to be able to know
chances are zero yeah I'll do it I'll do
it in paint because it's just a general
idea this was one of the maps that I did
design I didn't design all of them this
was the one that looked like oh I guess
I guess I guess I can just use continual
lines oh man there's gonna be great
there's gonna be great I'm looking
forward to it yeah it was just like that
and then the encampments were arranged a
little bit like this this yeah it was
like these were the encampments and they
were connected this way so there was a
pretty short rustic dish the dirt dirt
dish dance between team a and B so team
a and B were there we had here Oh mines
H and H that would kill entire armies
actually they'd said that they went on
to be supreme commanders in the Pacific
but then they were subsequently arrested
for war crimes and executed but their
descendants live on the map still there
so there you have it
you know the cycle of life and history
so anyway the point that I was trying to
make before I sort of confused myself
here was that B would go ahead and build
a bunch of encampments and then he
wouldn't be able to get to like these
ones back here he couldn't get to them
because they were not you know he
couldn't find them so that's that's
definitely something to worry about like
if maybe maybe what you should do is say
no I'm just sort of speaking off the top
of my head here is if you can't get
there and you're a robot and you're like
trying to path around them maybe you
should like send a signal to this fellow
that he should suicide and then like the
team should remember from now on into
the future of time that they shouldn't
try to build something there and then
maybe that'll be like the new route to
the expansion of new colonies and
exploring space for the benefit of
humanity so we see that they can be
blocked off don't know exactly how to
fix that problem we saw other issues
like like like team team zero or 116
they shouted attack and they died at
around 2000 - that was too sad that I
have the match here and it was like they
were cut off and maybe that look that
was an exception so definitely want to
like look for exceptions that will take
place if you're cut off and maybe just
like communicate to the other bases hey
I'm cut off please kill yourself
and I'm sure they'll comply like luckily
battlecode is not like the actual world
where it would be really hard to make
that argument to them they're like yeah
but but it's me I've heard I've heard a
little bit about Rush distance we had
one map that was called something like I
don't remember what it was called but we
kept calling it bad ideas where and the
map was like this it was a man that that
map was fantastic I was I didn't make
this one it had a big minefield in the
middle and then there was a a and B
located here and then on the very edges
of the map there were there were
encampments like in these corners and so
the idea was that if you actually take
some of you like you're pretty close
here this distance was I don't know 15
or something and so if you would send
your guys out in this way by the time
you built the encampment like first of
all you losing soldiers second they're
not gonna help you defend the enemy's
just gonna go ahead and kill you so like
if you see this distance I mean I think
a decent set of heuristics for a map
should be the following like like here's
here's like map map heuristics your is
to because I think that you could say
like distance to enemy and distance to
closest encampment and can't and then
you could do I guess that's like that's
pretty much all you need because I think
distance enemy is kind of kind of
unimportant what you should do is like
number of Mines to the enemy and that
sort of encapsulates distance and so
then you could be like okay if this
distance is big and this number is small
then there you go so all you got to do
is say like that number minus that
number and now you're starting to have
like something that you can compare to
like if it's big if this quantity is
greater than some number then do
something anyway you guys get the idea
we had a couple of maps where we had
lanes next to the mines I think we do
that quite a bit like some of the maps
that we gave you initially you could
just walk straight to the enemy if you
path around the mines and the lanes
weren't that
complicated like like all you have to do
is make one little turn and then you're
going straight to the enemy all the way
and we saw some teams use this but we
also saw them put encampments on the
lanes and then they couldn't walk there
I think there was one very critical map
one very critical match and that match
went something like this
all right some of you
obsessive-compulsive you're getting a
little bit annoyed by these little bits
okay there you go
I think on the map that I'm describing
it had these lanes like this and so
these are the mines that I'm drawing and
then between those we saw the
encampments that you could capture so
I'm just gonna make it slightly more
symmetrical we had team a over here and
Team B over here and the teams were just
like lined up exactly with the mines so
that if you counted the mines directly
between you and the enemy it was a large
number but if you counted this number it
was a zero number so what team a you
started doing and I'll just recap
because not all of you will have seen
that match is they started like defusing
these mines this way but simultaneously
they were capturing encampments so I'm I
believe they wouldn't they like didn't
think that there was a straight path to
the enemy because whenever they captured
something they also like they also got
these as soon as possible so they could
never really get around and
simultaneously B was building up a
minefield and and researching nuke yeah
nukes for the win
so I think it was it was pretty weird
you know we ended up seeing I guess I
guess you could classify it as almost
three strategies we you know there was
there's a rush there's an econ strategy
and then there's a nuke strategy like
these are there's overlap of course but
it almost seems like there are three
strategies in this map for this
particular map we saw that econ which
was his building these encampments like
if he didn't build those he would have
gone straight to the enemy would have
been great
this econ strategy was defeated by the
nuke so I'm just gonna do an arrow you
know econ on a large map would kill a
rush and honest you know and on a small
map a rush would kill a nuke like this
is this rock-paper-scissors
no but like given a map set it can be
rock-paper-scissors II
it can be scissors II anyway the point
is point is that whenever we have
something like this you know if you're
not taking into account the map so that
so it's just like pick it at random then
one result that you get is that the
tournament can like not make sense and I
think a lot of you and that's like very
it's it's more than just like some
simple you know concept in your head
that the tournament isn't making sense
well because because the basis of a
tournament is that when it's done you
know who's the best right it's supposed
to be that like teams are they've got
like a fundamental goodness and that the
top knee top team is best but if you
have three teams rock paper and scissor
and you hold the tournament what is the
tour what's the point of the tournament
but there's they're not gonna find
anything out at the end and of course
you all know this and and if you feel it
very and my point is that you feel it so
viscerally when it ends up happening so
the only solution is to use that map
data and to say okay I know it's a short
map or I know it's a long a large map or
something along those lines that's the
only thing that you got to do and I'm
very confident we're gonna see a whole
lot of that in the following matches not
in the ones we're gonna watch today in
the ones that are gonna be submitted to
the subsequent tournaments so we saw the
lanes next to the mines
we saw some really good positioning of
artillery the it made the difference
between victory and loss in a lot of
cases and I'd like to point out
especially in the presence of my
simulator here that a little artillery
can go a long way so I don't know how
many of you have had a chance to look at
the latest update of my battlecode
simulator but it works the following way
so here I'm going to compare two
strategies this strategy is to build
robots and know and can't no generators
or suppliers and this strategy is just a
continued building to stands for a
supplier so there you can see the first
strategies in green house that show up
that shows up pretty well the first
strategy in Green is to just build the
soldiers and you hit the maximum and
then the second strategy here you can
see now in this updated version of this
battle code simulator that you actually
do lose some units you lose units that
you would have had those soldiers are
destroyed in capturing the encampments
and then you only pay it off later so
here you see the 150 rounds or so
between
you know starting to buy those things
and having it pay off and you can
similarly see that you know that round
number is gonna change like if you only
build two of these things it's gonna be
it's gonna be quite different and well I
guess it ends up paying off at about the
same time that's curious
that's pretty curious but I'm sure I'm
sure it has a its basis in fact let's
let's just double check here the
supplier the supplier suppliers do
reduce your spawn delay so here on the
Left I've provided a table and this is
all available on the internet so you
don't need Mathematica because I did I
did also say this as a PDF but you can
make this yourself in Microsoft Excel or
something like that where you see the
number of suppliers on the left like you
know going from 0 up up on through
there's some incredibly large number
which we did see in this tournament if
you guys saw I really love to watch some
of those macro games and then we see on
the old spec what the spawn delay would
have been and then the latest spec so
the spec used to be 10 times 0.9 5 to
the N where n is the number of suppliers
the latest spec is 100 divided by 10
plus n so the effect is that now at the
latest spawn delay we go down from 10
faster so you see here we're at 6 when
it the old one was at 7 but later on
were higher so we sort of level off much
sooner and so we're at 2 here when the
other ones at 1 so there's a there's a
crossover and it's sort of favoring
getting them earlier anyway my point is
we can go with number of suppliers and
the spawn delay so when I get one
supplier I should see a spawn delay of
that improves by one and so you can say
like ok that the headquarters is
producing hit points per round like
that's the point of the headquarters I
mean sure number of units is a different
metric the number of hit points because
units deal damage not hit points but
it's sort of similar because you're
dealing damage and taking damage and you
know there you go it's all question of
micro when you get right down to it it's
all very clear and straightforward so
hit points per round is 4 if you build a
single artillery like okay you build you
build a single supplier now your spawn
delay is 9 so you're producing 4 point 4
repeating hit points per round so that's
an additional point for repeating hit
points for round that's what you got out
of building that supplier you got this
and the next one you build will get you
this I mean if you build this one you
get even more I mean some of them that
you build don't get you anything
so you can see like incremental hit
points per round but look all these
numbers none of them are that big
whereas if you've got something like an
artillery it can get to a large number
of hit points per round because really
what you're interested in is not just
hit points for your team it's a
difference between your team and the
enemy hit team hit points so if you
build artillery that does get shots off
I mean like you can if it shoots all the
time
then it's gonna be dealing 40 damage
every 20 turns and that's like infinity
isn't it that's 40 40 over that's two
hit points per turn that's that's a lot
I mean of course it's not gonna do that
because a lot of the time it isn't
shooting but if it's shooting only like
20 percent of the time then it's 2 times
1/5 and now you have point 4 so it's
starting to be competitive to get an
artillery compared to a supplier so
that's just one way of looking at things
definitely worth thinking about I I
should say because you know one of these
artilleries can be as we've seen in some
of these matches worth its weight so now
the question is is this code working
properly and I think the answer is no
actually in in characteristic fashion so
here I built one supplier and the
production rate of robots is
approximately identical to the way that
it was so I'm just gonna debug this a
second let's see here I think I think we
have here okay so that's the supplier
number there and the question is if that
supplier number is there and the spawn
time is being updated then why wouldn't
it take effect because that certainly
does look like the latest spec well in
any case I think I think it would be
safe for us just to start with 1 and
that's like a decent fudge factor let's
let's do that let's start with let's
start with oh my god I'm terrible
terrible person let's see yeah let's see
it happen I'll figure it out later so
there now we see a little bit of a
difference and we get the second one
should have okay that had a big effect
was it supposed to it was the third one
should have no effect so let's let's
just double check that and then what
we're gonna end up doing is we'll watch
some matches okay so let's go back to
having two and now we'll go to having
three and yeah the slope didn't change I
don't think the slope changed it just
moved left and right because we had to
lose another soldier so that's good I
think it was just an offset of one I
guess that makes perfect sense to me for
summary
yeah I'll understand it in fact let's
pretend I understand it now it's just a
question of when we're pretending I want
to understand again not a question of
whether all right so let's go ahead and
watch some matches because I really want
to illustrate a few interesting things
about minds and micro and so on so let's
go all of you can do it I don't know if
you've seen this but you simply go to
tournaments and you go to results and
you click on Sprint bracket and now you
have access to all the matches that you
can download I mean it's not as great as
like being able to for example get
everybody else's code so you can play
against it infinitely but it's pretty
good and you can also convert this match
data into XML files that you can parse
to like find matches that match a
certain characteristic like for instance
let's just do an example I guess we'll
just pick any random match let's pick
the final the final match I don't know
the final match was I mean well I think
what ended up happening is we started
having teams that rushed get to the
finals and I think that was map
dependent in the future it may be less
so that rush teams are really making it
up to the finals and there may be other
like an econ team like we see one of the
best econ teams here hey I just met you
was actually a cross between rush and
econ we saw them sometimes build like
absolutely massive numbers of macro
buildings and other times we saw them
not I see one question a mister pipe
Nexus o best of five matches that's been
introduced as a concept sorry about my
misunderstanding best of five matches
may be introduced later but it's still
on the table because it's a it would
require largely working aver of our
tournament code because of course we
write things in the most flexible and
reusable way possible yeah I think they
do let's we can actually go straight
into a match and just double-check that
because all we have to do is go to one
of those matches where one of the teams
walls itself in and just look at that
because then they have suppliers but not
but not soldiers so let's go to that one
I think I have it loaded already those
poor those poor fellows yeah these I'm
sorry team zero I'm sorry but
you go they have a supplier and they are
team 116 and they're steady at 225
resources where is that I don't know is
that is that more than they would be
spending if they were doing nothing I
think I think it might be there's a
chance there's a chance that it that it
could be I'm gonna go with yes but
that's sort of a guess I don't know no
no I don't know it probably is it
probably takes upkeep I guess that's
another thing that may be wrong with my
simulate anyway I'm tired of saying that
I'm wrong let's talk about how I'm right
come on well guys alright so let's open
up a match I I want to start before you
know before teams that are rushing are
winning so like citizen snips for
example I think was doing some decent
rush some decent macro so let's open
that one up I think I was pretty
impressed with that team there were also
some teams that were brand new like that
that came from the bottom of the ladder
and I think we'll have a chance today to
talk about those a little bit as well so
I'm just gonna make sure that I'm
looking at the latest the latest one arm
and please sort them would you mind
sorting them computer thank you man I
tell you you know there's a problem with
insubordination these time so yeah we
see we teach team snips on the right is
getting vision you know visual was not a
very popular upgrade but they're
building these artillery and the in the
front and then they're building supplier
in the back I think that's a that's a
pretty a pretty interesting approach and
because of the map layout they're ending
up using the artillery quite a bit like
so we see we see a good shot there it's
not bad
it does it does seem to deal some damage
no does do it deals no damage to allied
units so that's great but I think later
on we might we might see yeah I don't
know if that was such a great shot
because we took out two enemies at the
cost of two allied units so I don't know
that seem like breaking even in my eyes
but so there's something you can do
there with writing artillery code to try
to avoid allied units like like maybe I
don't know you shoot at you could
literally compute the value of every
tile but it seems pretty expensive so
I'm not sure exactly what the best way
to do that is so we see them getting
vision one of the rare teams to get
vision and we see them upgrading their
interlaced with building their other
robots and their other structures so
that I don't know how I feel about
interlacing one thing on another so it's
like I guess the idea is that it's not
quite as fast as researching it straight
out but it's not quite as slow as like
getting it after you get all your robots
but actually when when it comes right
down to it if you build like like let's
get out a simple program here such as
paint like if you build for robots like
1 2 3 & 4 and you research like 25%
which I'll indicate as like maybe
there's like a completion bar and you
research like I don't know this much and
then this much and then this much and
then you're done like how is that any
different from research from getting
like robot robot robot robot and then
getting out the full bar I don't think
it's incredibly different and it may be
just that it gives you more flexibility
to make decisions part way because like
maybe if you do this thing which I
should change the color here like maybe
if you get three of these straight out
then now you're sort of fixed and you
can't finish this for a certain amount
of time whereas here you give yourself
more flexibility to like cancel this
part way through but I just feel like
this is the stronger move because if you
if you go up against this team versus
that team then if there's an engagement
at time this time then right then and
there you're gonna have four on three
and so when it comes down to here you're
gonna have like you know two guys left
and he's gonna have one guy and it's
gonna be you know pretty clear who's
gonna win and it doesn't matter that
both of you have this stuff at the end
it's just not it's just not gonna matter
so I I don't know how I feel about the
interlacing so we see a bunch of that
and we also see here that you know team
70 is a team that either rushes or goes
for a heavy macro play and I get the
feeling that on this map they've just
they've decided that the rush distance
like the distance from one team to the
other is not huge it's not that big and
so and there aren't that many mines
either so I think this is the reason why
they're doing this rush you know I think
it's pretty impressive that even though
they're down on units like pretty
concern we see two units from blue and
one unit from red nevertheless red is
able to like hold off this this this
blue attack I think I think
team 70 has some really excellent micro
and I will remind you that the team 70
has one author who was a former member
of a team with Corey who spoke yesterday
at lecture and you remember that Corey
talked all about micro micro being the
important thing that wins matches we're
gonna see that again and again you saw
that in the Sprint tournament and I have
ways of indicating again to you in
videos that we watched today that that
was incredibly key in a lot of
circumstances we saw that happen and so
it makes perfect sense that we would see
red have some really good micro but at
the same time like he's not gonna make
any inroads against this player who's
doing artillery and you got to wonder
whether that's detectable like whether
he can tell that he's dying to artillery
and whether he can like tell the main
base hey you know this is our Tillery so
we've got basically two choices one we
bunch up a lot of Units and we make sure
we attack all at once and spread out
enough so that we're not taking splash
damage from that artillery or we got to
get shields or we got to do a massive
econ play like basically we got those
three choices and one of the neither of
those choices neither of those three are
among the choice of just simply sending
one unit at a time so I think a lot
let's see did you see that happen that's
pretty surprising like you see you see
the enemy attack and you see red
outnumbered so like this is two enemies
to one red okay and the two enemies are
sort of like grouping around the enemy
headquarters because they're not really
prioritizing attacking that one red guy
they're sort of just going toward like
the enemy it seems it's not I mean it's
not that obvious that they're
prioritizing enemy units so what ends up
happening is this one red guy is
managing to kite and attack only one
blue guy see that and I guess there's
probably like awesome stuff that you
could read in their indicator strings
here like remember that when we show the
tournament the indicator string bar is
not there like that's just not part of
the tournament viewer but if you watch
the replay you can read their indicator
strings and you might learn something
about what those robots are trying to
think about or trying to do so here you
see the red it's like really kiting
these guys and he's almost using his
headquarters as like a defensive
structure like you can see here he's
almost come back because he's got two
units and this guy's capturing an
encampment and you can't cancel that
he's almost like recovering here and
just through the use of micro I think
it's very impressive and it's only
because he sort of walks in to that
artillery fire again that it seems like
he has he has some trouble I mean I
there are multiple ways of reading the
system you know reading what happened in
this match but but I think that was
pretty interesting this is like one of
the only shields that we ever see I
don't see any reason why blue would have
decided to build it
especially in this location especially
given this guy has no artillery
especially especially especially so I
yeah I think this game is pretty much
forgotten but you know and I think this
one is also foregone conclusion okay
here's a great example so he has built
three suppliers okay three suppliers out
of team 216 and there you go he has 180
whereas at the beginning I think you
were stable at 194 so there we have our
definitive answer to that question I
think you are stable at 194 so these do
take hit point they do take and upkeep
these these supplier units that he does
end up building so that's that's good
that makes me feel happy so now it goes
on to around three I mean yeah you gotta
you gotta check that okay said it before
don't repeat myself
very good so team 70 team seven both
teams are deciding this is a macro map
pretty interesting because once again we
saw a team 70 not do macro but look at
this look at it he's not running
straight from macro he's got this
decision in mind that's one generator
and four suppliers
Wow let's let's just rewind just that we
whine just thought widow bit just a
little bit right over there so yeah he's
getting the generator first and then
those three meanwhile he's getting he's
getting fusion he's already got fusion I
think he he prioritizes that upgrade
like it's pretty strange because you see
him I think get it before even his first
unit so here we're looking at around 20
around 15 16 17 he still hasn't built a
unit whereas blue has built two units
already you know it's questionable
whether prioritizing fusion is gonna be
that good because he prioritizes fusion
but then doesn't actually use all that
energy he's still at 1600 you know does
he ever actually use it maybe you know
it's gonna be later and it's you know
this team could be even more powerful
than it was probably perhaps if it
perhaps did that a little bit later so
yeah well let's go back and let's think
about this because this setup here is is
meant to sort of strike at a certain
time and the time when he's meant to
strike like imagine imagine setting it
up this way were you like okay I know
that depending on the
number of macro buildings I build that
will give me an attack timing where
it'll be the perfect moment for you for
me to attack because I'm just running
out of resources I'm just hitting a peak
of units well maybe that attack timing
should exactly match how long is tomato
will take for me to get to the enemy now
you could use the headquarters to say
you know to just calculate explicitly it
will take me this long you get to the
enemy I had better have some macro up by
that time and you know that could be
exactly what he's doing so let's do a
little check in Mathematica where we'll
say he's gonna build four of these
suppliers and he's gonna build one
generator so there we see that he's
gonna cross over and he's gonna be even
with the enemy of 200 so let's hope that
he attacks the enemy closer to 300 let's
see what happens so there he's just
pausing like all his units are pausing
it's around 269 they're not doing
anything it's brown 300 they're still
not doing anything I guess it's because
he's taking more bases that he's decided
like okay I have I have something that's
a lot of Units I'm pretty sure this is a
defensive move that he's just gonna move
out here and he's expecting these to
defend him unfortunately you know that's
not exactly on the midpoint between the
two armies and you got to wonder whether
that's a deliberate idea or whether he's
chosen to go in this direction for some
other reason because we're gonna see
blue go ahead and take out a lot of
those bases that a lot of that stuff
that he had on the bottom so we see once
again these that then Red Hat ends up
using and does in most of his matches he
ends up using his reinforcing stream as
a defensive as a defensive tool if he
didn't have that stream of Units
continually coming out of the base
there's no way he would be able to
defend this because these guys are not
programmed to turn around and come back
once again blue has this great like look
at this positioning I think it's it's
probably not just great positioning it's
probably just that every other time he's
building one or the other because we see
another artillery here and here and here
and here and here whereas you know red
has not built a single artillery so the
question is you know is it is it the
building of one thing or another that
has made the difference in this match
because we're starting to see like red
is starting to get a lot more units and
that artillery is not always shooting so
it's I think it's a pretty open question
whether it was actually worth it because
in this long match it ends up
that red prevails so yeah that's I mean
it's pretty interesting how red has got
like a relatively simple move he's just
like pickin rush or econ and when he
goes econ he goes econ all the way and
when he goes rush he goes rush all the
way and his micros fantastic and those
little things alone little though I may
call them are you know are really
significant okay so that's spending a
long time on just one match let's look a
little bit about let's look a little bit
at Game of Death Game of Death is a team
that started out really low so let's see
your game of death so we can click on
them here under battle code teams we see
that they were 13 and 3 the ranking was
at the bottom of the scrimmage of the
scrimmage ranks so let's have a look at
how they made it up to round 4 from the
very bottom round like they had a bad
they had a bad match a bad seed at the
beginning and they made it all the way
up to here how were they able to do that
because they must be doing something
right this is a you know like what's
this turnaround let's let's have a look
at this so I'm gonna go over here I'm
gonna run that match and I'm pretty sure
we'll have time to talk about all of the
interesting things that happen in this
one and in the next ones so here on the
right we have we have that team that new
team which has but we you know which is
upsetting one after another other team
and he's gonna build suppliers so he's
built two suppliers and he's building a
few mines around headquarters and it
looks like he's just rolling over team
172 which was which was drunk asaurus
drunk a source is another one of these
rush players and you'd expect a rush to
be pretty effective on this map so what
happened I think it's worth mentioning
that you know a rush player would do
well to get like if you're if this rush
player is not really padding around
mines if that's not the way that they're
planning to play the game then they
probably ought to get diffusion
I mean they've spent a few a few rounds
buying fusion doesn't seem to make that
much sense to me
I think he might get like one free round
at the beginning it seems like a lot of
people will just put one point into
something but you know the amount of
time it takes him to get to the enemy he
can compute because he he just went
straight there so he can compute that
time and he can say alright was that
worth it
it's also worth mentioning that I think
in a lot of these engagements he's busy
defusing mines during combat and like we
said before you can't attack while
you're defusing a mind so like the part
of the best reason of getting diffusion
is so that you only have five rounds of
inaction so that like let's say nobody's
around
it's perfectly safe great time to defuse
of mines you start defusing that mind
now you see the enemy you can't cancel
the diffusion process so if you were
gonna do a 12:00 turn diffusion and you
see the enemy and he's at a distance of
wait what's the distance all we have to
do is look it up so let's go to my
useful specs document which is neither
handy nor dandy it's it's in fact much
more serious and much more useful than
both of those terms would suggest so
range 14 is your sight range if you can
see a unit that's three tiles away I can
zoom in a little bit more here it's
raster and so it looks kind of silly I
always think it's interesting how when
you rest or something sometimes it
becomes orange on one side and blue on
the other side I'm sure some of you in
this room understand it and I'm sure
that some of you in this room don't care
to understand it and never want to so
he's three units away right the enemy's
three units away and you just started
defusing the round before so if that's a
12-round diffusion then by the time he
gets to you you've still got like seven
or nine rounds left if you subtract
correctly and depending on the turn
counts and whatever that's a lot of time
that you're just gonna spend doing
nothing and how long does it take for
the enemy to kill you they deal six
damage per round you have 40 hit points
I can't divide but that sounds like sort
of seven ish seven rounds well look at
that so you had 12 you didn't see
anybody they had time to approach and
kill you and go away before you finish
like that's really lousy even if they
get one hit off on you that's gonna make
a huge difference because this is a
knife-edge game it's in it's a game of
instabilities because we don't start you
off with like a command center that
deals damage for example we don't give
you that many defensive advantages so as
soon as the enemy gets like a couple
more units in you it's just gonna start
pushing in that direction unless they
start making mistakes so that's one of
the reasons why I like defusing a mine
with without diffusion and without
vision is a problem let's say you have
both vision and diffusion I mean of
course they're very expensive upgrades
but let's say that you've got them well
now it's only going to take five rounds
you something and you have you can see a
unit that's five tiles away so let's say
he's over here you don't see him you
start diffusing now he's starting to
show up and he's moving toward you by
the time he gets there you're done
defusing and you can start shooting
that's pretty that's a that's a pretty
big difference and I think that's one of
the reasons why we see a lot of
successful rush teams go ahead and get
that diffusion whereas we see drunkest
auras here not getting diffusion you
know we see decent micro on both teams
side I don't know I don't know exactly
if this is good micro coming out of both
they're certainly out of a lot of motion
going on you know it's it's it's sort of
anybody's guess here both teams are
defusing mines they're just sort of like
watching each other maybe they're you
know they're sort of playing Parcheesi
with the mind effusion exchanging tips
on how not to get blown up it's it's
very I think it's a very odd thing to
see I think it's it's quite strange but
but yeah yeah the point has been made
the point the point has been abundantly
made another thing if you're retreating
and you are adjacent to the enemy I
think we've seen this a lot and I think
that is kind of what's going on in some
of these cases like like maybe this guy
is Jason the enemy and maybe he's
retreating because he's like he's got
one Energon and get me the hell out of
here I think he's like maybe or was
trying to retreat at some point but it's
a bad idea
to defuse a mind when you're adjacent to
the enemy like don't start don't just
don't start it's like smoking just don't
start yes this advertisement brought to
you by the American Society for lungs I
don't know I I just thought that sounded
right so yeah here once again we see
this is the same two players but in this
case blue team just I don't know he's
like dancing or something it's not it's
not super effective he's building nukes
like so how he decided like yeah now is
the time to get nukes like I've gotten
pickaxe but I'm not using it so I think
but no to be to be fair I think what
he's trying to do is like lay a bunch of
mines into a minefield and he's doing
that using his pickaxe but I think maybe
he's thinking all right there's a lot of
neutral mines these are supposed to help
me out I shouldn't destroy them but but
nevertheless you know the red team is
able to you know is able to just roll
this over so it does go on to a third a
third match but like what a difference
what a difference we see here without so
you know he's getting close to his
maximum but we see he's optimized for
this look at his units he's using 500
byte codes that's effectively zero so
he's gonna be able to get up to the full
40 units and that's gonna you know that
that what that strength of that 40 units
what is the strength point of that 40
units well it's simply go back here to
here to here that that 400 like that 400
round counter that's exactly that's
exactly when you hit your maximum if you
haven't built any upgrades and that's
exactly when he arrives at the enemy
base so unless we start changing the
maps you know not getting upgrades is
gonna be fine for you as long as you
know as long as you're not doing what he
did in the last round which was somehow
bad I mean you got to have that clump of
Units and I think one thing that we see
again and again is once a team loses its
clump of Units it sends them in one by
one now it's not obvious that that's a
bad idea because we've seen teams win
that way so what do you do okay now that
was pretty one-sided what happened there
what did blue have more units or did red
have more units okay let's go and say
this is 3 by 5 so that's 15 units cuz
these 3 go into it and that's 18 so
that's 18 units this is 3 by 5 with 3
missing so that's 15 units plus okay so
that's 18 19 20 so this guy's got 20 and
I guess that counts for these guys that
blue left behind so Red's got a slight
advantage all teams are defusing mines
these two could be fighting there's no
reason for them not to be fighting now
red has red has managed to kill this guy
off very handily because of that
advantage we saw before in Corey's
lecture how he's talking about this
being a very unstable situation where if
you've got one gap between the two the
person who closes that gap first will
win so let's see if somebody is gonna
close that gap
well now look at look at how much damage
blue is doing like that that's pretty
impressive and I think part of that is
we're seeing that a lot of Reds units
are just spending time defusing this one
in this one in particular also this one
which is right in the middle these three
in the back definitely not wants to
ignore so yeah blue ends up coming in
here and capitalizes on a little
advantage now red okay red is still
attacking like at this like there's a
point in this battle one of the thing
about
battles is it you know where the enemy
is right so you can you can make that
count you can count them you can say all
right we're about to lose this battle
here's an interesting question for you
you're losing a battle what do you do do
you call for reinforcements and say okay
if we have more reinforcements we won't
lose as badly or do you save the
reinforcements please go back to the
base and regroup it's your only chance
to live you know what what is what is
what you say I mean I don't think we
have I'm hitting the B button
there's no broadcast going on in the
whole map but you could imagine the case
where they would be like okay I'm
telling my allies get the hell out of
there so and this guy this guy it's like
he sees a very bad situation and here
his two tiles away from these two tiles
away from an enemy
he's got the choice like do I move close
that gap I mean that's a bad idea right
from Corey's lecture you don't close the
gap with two because then you won't have
the attack advantage that's not a good
idea but what's he gonna do
so let's click on it okay and he moved
in and what's he gonna do again oh he's
kiting a little bit well he's only
fighting one of the enemy that's not so
bad
but he ends up being destroyed I mean
what can he expect I think it'd be very
reasonable for you to write code that
says okay if the enemy is there what am
I gonna do a lot of times we've seen
teams back away they try to do in
retreat of course the retreat doesn't
work if you're already engaged let's say
you're not engaged
okay we're smart people we don't retreat
when we're engaged that that would be a
bad idea you know we keep with it we
have our commitment but we back we back
out where do we back out we've seen
teams time and again try to back away
and then they get stuck because there's
mines in the way like they only cleared
a very narrow path through to the enemy
so why not remember the path that you
took to get to that enemy so that you
can then just follow that backwards like
you have omnidirectional view so that
might work it might not might be a
terrible idea but I'm just putting it
putting it out there because you can
save map locations pretty easily like
two to an array and then it's like okay
just pop that array back so you like
pushing to an array and then you're
popping the array values back so it's
like you know the zone ordered list of
where I've been and where I want to go
back to and you know what I want to do
with my life and whether I want to visit
Paris and eat baguettes so it's like a
full integrated system for travelling
the world and I think red could
definitely benefit from that especially
in a case like this I mean what do you
would he be able to come back from this
probably no I mean just a little bit of
macro from blue I think
ends up making
huge difference but but nevertheless
it's worth it's worth mentioning so like
why does why does red not win this map
we've seen rushman rush teams do well I
think it's it's just because blue
actually built any units at all but you
know there you have it there you have it
good game that's a good game let's make
sure that we're getting to everything
getting to everything so we've seen
we've seen some games where we had a run
around where one team would run around
would sort of circumvent the other team
and deal damage to the headquarters as
we've said before the wind condition is
as follows you know I don't think we've
been that straightforward on what the
wind conditions are first and foremost
it's a headquarter hitpoints so if you
can get one hit off the enemy that's a
good time to just back out you know
maybe maybe the time now is to just lay
some mines and play defensively as long
as the you have registered a hit on the
enemy head headquarters which you could
like let's say your if your soldier
moves toward the enemy headquarters and
is adjacent
that's a nice time for him to broadcast
hey I was adjacent to the enemy
headquarters ergo I did damage to him
that's like that's a given that's always
true unless the enemy has a med bay
adjacent to his headquarters dealing
damage no that's not gonna work had well
there you go
there you go folks you've heard it from
the words of somebody knowledgeable so
yeah so there you go so you would know
so you could you could message and you
could play defensively headquarter head
points first and foremost number of
encampments second number of mines third
number of robots third fourth good one
yes we saw some runarounds we saw we saw
some teams running around the enemy and
we've also seen like a like especially
at the lower levels of the bracket if
your headquarters is under attack it is
of paramount importance tantamount to
paramount importance that you come back
and defend it definitely worth sending a
signal you know allied it soldiers
either protect me or you know just
declare yourselves null and void and
you're not gonna get a Christmas bonus
so like like I said before you know Game
of Death was a great team we saw it we
saw them get really far velociraptors
drunkest Oris and cordage we saw them
rush and be very effective
with that you know there are ways of
making a right rush more effective we
saw them do those things and I think it
was very impressive we saw a soda which
was a really good team that they did
they did well in the newbie tournament
last last year and I'm excited to see
them back again this year there were
certain things they didn't do that were
kind of strange you know and a lot of
teams here probably felt that they could
have done better you know these little
edged cases end up being so important
like on little forts they're standing
right next to the enemy this was so sad
they're standing right next to the enemy
while the enemy research is nuke and
they're like surrounding them they've
got tons of Units but they just didn't
move in I mean this this is certain like
state machine code maybe a couple of
minds maybe they had indigestion there
was there's clearly a good reason there
but they just didn't do it and you know
checking for those edge cases is is just
so hard to do I think this is all gonna
be so cleared up though we're gonna see
some great stuff hey I just met you
again we saw there there's sort of
bipolar response to maps I thought that
was that was just fantastic absolutely
fantastic I want to I want to finish
finish by talking a little bit about
sort of the way the game might change in
the future so you know that you saw a
certain specs and you saw certain maps
this is the kind of thing that we change
after the Sprint tournament or the
seeding tournament where we go okay we
want to tweak this a little to make sure
the game is interesting like that's
that's our big that's our big focus like
we want the game to be interesting we
don't want it to be random we want it we
want it to showcase how amazing you guys
are so if it ends up being the case that
rushes are the best and that like a
little bit of micro code makes a
difference between winning and losing a
hundred percent of the time like that I
don't think that's that great I don't
like that so let's say that there could
be changes now if when you hear that you
probably go AHA he's going to tell me
the changes that are going to happen but
he's not allowed to tell me the changes
so he's going to tell them
hypothetically but they will actually
happen but no that's not the case I'm
just coming up with them hypothetically
I guarantee it okay so the changes are
okay we got a nuke the nuke is 400
rounds okay we have we have maximum the
maximum soldier count for a rush is at
400 rounds we've seen that like I'm
using my mathematical simulator we've
seen it with
soldiers I'm sure you've written it
you've wrote written it yourself I mean
it's it's technically 200 rounds if
you're if you're you know computing
digits of pi
yeah because as we've said before that
that would mean that you have a whole
lot less to have so that's 200 that's
400 rounds that's 400 rounds the minimum
the minimum distance between
headquarters is 10 the maximum distance
between headquarters is I think we said
it was 200 rounds of walking mining I
think that's what we said it was so it's
not so in the current set you're not
going to get a map that's like this
that's like 400 on the side I think the
maximum we said is 70 so if it were 70
on a side then there would be exactly 70
mines between you and the enemy times 5
rounds per mine is 350 so like that's
the absolute worst worst worst that it
could possibly be and that would look
like this like that would be all grey a
full of mines and that's just not gonna
happen like realistically realistically
we're gonna put in like some silly path
and you can just walk there so so with
the current spec the point that I'm
trying to make I mean okay you could add
you could add 25 because it'll take you
a little bit of time to research
diffusion so you can get to the other
side but my point is that this is only
350 like and and so you're really only
gonna have 200 rounds of walking and the
fact is that we don't want to get back
close to that number so we end up like
99% of the time right now we're making
it like 100 rounds of walking okay sure
so it's six that's six very good so
that's a six and that's a four twenty
plus 25 equals ugly no it's a four-foot
I don't know it's ugly
you made my diagram ugly you know what
I'd rather be correct and beautiful I
mean oh I can't have both okay so anyway
you get like poor diagram I knew you
well yeah so there you go see just
looking at these numbers here you can
add them up and you get like 730 and it
doesn't mean
no I'm kidding you can see these numbers
like they just don't make sense for econ
strategies they just don't make sense so
what we might do and what I've been
telling the others I would like to do is
set nuke to like 600 let's say nuke
we're 600 this can stay at 4 it like it
doesn't matter what things are in
absolute terms it matters what they are
compared to other terms so so the
soldier rush okay let's keep that 400
the nuke is 600 let's make the maximum
distance like 300 so now these are
changing these are changing at the same
rate the nuke and the distance are
changing at the same rate so nukes will
be no more favored what will be favored
is like now now soldiers are like now
it's farther to get to the enemy and you
still have the same number of like you
have maybe a smaller number of soldiers
relative to what the other guy has so
this would favor econ like if we
increase nuke and the distance then
that'll favorite econ strategy and so
then I think we'll start to see some
more interesting games where this like
just a couple more encampments being
taken and you know this computation is
moving in wonderful directions and it's
moving that way under the fiery engines
of your spirit thank you for attending
the last lecture and I'll be around here
for questions afterward
you